thank you guys uh as he was entering the
studio he uh gave me a a smile a sly
smile like faviano you feel like you
survived this one this feels like a
victory for you doesn't it yeah i mean
the position was so dead
and i was down on time too i mean that
wasn't the biggest of my issues like he
he was winning and um
and he allowed my
what i thought was my only trick
um i mean i think instead of rook f3
which is probably winning but fg3 okay
like uh there's no need to cause these
complications
and then after rook f3 i was happy i
found this bishop h4
uh at least some chances i mean
you've felt the lazy man's way of f2
takes g3 is just pretty winning what can
i do here my rook is trapped
yeah we didn't see it either but another
move that uh after rook takes f3
has to uh back the question of what do
you do after is knight to d5 yeah yeah
this is what we were discussing i mean
this is for sure winning 97
i have to take with something on no no
on d4 of course
um
yeah maybe this one king e7
um rook d3
uh
i was thinking this is probably not many
chances although i can still try king
e65 and
hope for something um but i was maybe
thinking the work on g4 so if i take the
other way
i mean i was sure it's losing after
let's say rook d8 d4
take king e7 uh rook d3
let's say
yeah or wait who catches this but
perhaps you can go deep right after
kingdom six king e6 d5 take d6 says yeah
that's over um
yeah so so this is probably just
hopeless
um
but yeah he surprised me because he
at least like my moves become very easy
after 96 i didn't have to worry about if
it was
losing or not because uh
well i resigned with without any
with any other moves besides what i
played and we thought at this point
knight e2 just had to be played yeah you
guys consider this move uh king diet i
wasn't sure about it i4 yeah we've got
four take
i was thinking maybe rook d3 d4 is also
why but okay let's say we have four take
take
and probably king d7
uh
i thought it's it's not a hundred
percent lost you know and it's it's
either lost
um or black will
have significant drawing chances because
you know i'm only down upon the yes
e6 knight g6 is not winning e6 king d6
knight g6 um
bishop somewhere e7 uh yeah let's say
bishop g5 e7
bishop g5 i thought
maybe bishop g3 but e7 king d7 and
i get some counter play well i can start
to run with the c pawn but you know this
becomes a mess
uh
well running with the c pawn maybe i can
just take on e7 actually so
taking 97 is a
is a nice resource there
i mean also white white has to calculate
all sorts of pawn endings this is
this is a dream for me because
his task becomes very difficult but even
before this moment uh this move c5 that
you played we could not understand why
you came to that conclusion can you
explain your thrain of thought at this
point uh yeah desperation
i didn't i should have played a3 the
movie iv
yes that's clear maybe this pawn sack is
dubious maybe it's okay but
um definitely a3 here and then knight d5
this is a better version exactly then an
id5 a3 i
you know i calculate i calculated
something which doesn't work involving
rook d8 and knight f4 in something and
then after burning a lot of time i just
couldn't come up with the better idea
besides putting the opponent c4 sacking
b5 and
hoping for some compensation
um we thought he played it very well did
you feel also that he was playing it
quite well up to this point
yeah i i wasn't 100 sure because it's
very difficult to say what's most
accurate okay for both of us but
um
i mean certainly he always kept an
advantage right
you know i thought this king f1 was a
very nice movie because it stops my
knight f4 and it's tracks because of
rookie four exactly knight a7 first and
then rookie four exactly
so h5 also likes c5 a kind of a
desperation move no i i just uh didn't
realize how bad the position
in exchange up would be for me i thought
i would have drawing chances um or at
least not be losing and then when i got
there i was like
this cold realization that it's really a
dead end yeah
and uh yeah at this point we thought wow
and king f7 uh again uh so many moves
sorry uh to say at fabi but so many
moves not just of yours but
of his too weren't on our radars uh well
what what do i play here i just didn't
know
we thought h4 or yeah h4 no no no pardon
we did we did we had rook b8 on our
agenda oh but rook d3 rook b2 rook d7 i
just thought
i can i can't do this rook d3 rook b2
rook d7 and that was you just stopped
right here
well i calculated a little bit but i
thought this is losing um even though
you've actually got a rook that i mean
that this is maybe the first time you
have something
important but my active rook doesn't do
anything i really need to win this a
pawn which if i win it then knight fg5
comes and i thought okay i'm getting
mated can you take it yeah i might have
two five five and give up then i have to
give up the rook and i'm i have to play
rook b8 but his ruler can go behind the
pawn but why do you need to go rogue
beat i can take take bishop f8 hold on
let me catch up to the players so real
quick
you you're saying if you take on a3
f3 g5 right
but i thought king f7 was necessary yeah
i think king of seven is probably the
only chance but why is bishop a3 note
not good okay please bishop a3
knight
yeah
and
and i retreat all the way back
and rook d8 i just think it's over this
is not enough yeah a3
rook eight
eight two and then you just go into g
two two yeah yeah okay two and one day
the night will land on e6 yeah that's
over whoa okay so king f7 i mean
desperation and then you got to this
position where unfortunately for lavon's
fans
he let you
swindle him hit
right here
and when you played the move g6 were you
aware at this point that
the engines were going to give you a
zero zero you felt that this was going
to be a draw now yes sir i don't know if
you're aware but we don't have i know i
know but did you feel that it was a draw
that was my i didn't see any way for
white to
uh let's say proven advantage i was
thinking if he plays on like knight c7
or any knight move 97 king d8 95 i
thought was very logical and then
e6 yeah
um
yeah of course it's it's uh
it's still dangerous for black but it's
also dangerous for white because i'll
play
and run my g pawn
and his knights and pawn they're they're
very good but they're not really
you know promoting or mating me for the
moment king he ate here i thought and
uh i was
i didn't think i was worse let's say
so he could try to run a c yeah he can
do that but then you know his like c4 he
has to start to calculate rook d1 and
everything
uh
this is not three years old
yeah not really what you want exactly
well he's lost control
let's be very clear at that point so and
at the very very end did you consider
avoiding the
uh perpetual well i only have one way
right which is
after
e6 back my knight c7 kingdom knight c6 i
can play king c8 yes but um
i first of all i thought if he plays
rook f8
i can't play king d7 because of rook f2
and i lose my g pawn
uh so i have to go b7 and i don't i mean
anyone is your jeep
at the very least right yes clear it's
nice so nice so i have to go king b7 and
i don't know what i'm doing i mean maybe
i'm just mated at some point it's like
the only reason for me to play for a win
would be because he was lower on time
but exactly
you're not going to risk that no i
thought i'm i'm more likely to lose in
him if i do this it feels like in this
tournament you've been a cat with like
nine lives whether we go back to the
jeffrey zhang
armageddon or the sam savion
uh you feel like you're living life on
the edge
definitely today definitely i mean
armageddon you kind of expect that today
i think i was outplayed fully for most
of the game and
um just at the last moment i
i squeaked by with the draw you know um
but
yeah
but i also think in this tournament like
if you want to do well you're going to
have you're going to need your fair
share of luck exactly there's no way
it's just such a difficult tournament
all sorts of
time controls and right uh yeah it's
it's um i mean i think also lev on like
let's say yesterday had uh had his fair
share of
i mean we had so many questions about
fabi's uh play
do you have any specific moment that
really you just thought i
i don't understand chess anymore all
right let's take it to the opening i
want you i want just a
question about chas you got to this
position after the move
bishop b3 which was apparently a novelty
explain to us a little bit what goes on
through your mind
here no before the move a5 a4 you have
all these options
where do you think that this can get
dangerous for black and how do you make
a choice in which move to play when you
have so many options well i mostly
considered a4 i think it's by far the
most natural move if i allow him to play
a for himself he'll he'll have a certain
advantage
if i play bishop yeah queen e7 and i
don't know if he takes first and then a4
i think white is only can only be better
there
and if i play bishop b3 ab3 this is not
necessarily a bad structure but he gets
d4 very quickly
i mean i can play this this like yeah
knight g6 d4 and
and something but i felt like
more likely white is the one with the
slight edge
and so i spent most of my time
considering this complicated position
after d4
kind of when i found this idea of knight
d7 i settled on this and
it looked like a harmonious position
so i once i saw this i decided that i
can probably go go ahead with with a4 in
this position
and i didn't really consider knight h5
too much it really provoked me i should
probably play something besides knight
f4 but we thought queen e7 was a very
safe natural you keep your
but the move knight h5 was a surprise
for you too i mean yeah
it's just such a provocation and
and as usual i couldn't resist the most
concrete approach i should have just
played something normal and we would
have gotten
an easier game to play
uh while after knight f4 he
he really started to put pressure and i
think played very very well with the e
take e5 this is not obvious stuff no um
and yeah
i got a
pretty unpleasant position i mean you'd
rather be white here for sure absolutely
yeah
well
a big game for you tomorrow fab we will
let you go thank you for joining us and
uh wow uh great save
yeah absolutely and gives himself a
chance to finish off the tournament
tomorrow remember he will have the white
pieces against lavon he wins he's the
american cup champion